là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ligne
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter à votre place je la ramène un
peu moins mais si vous ne réussissez pas
c'est qu'il vous manque qu'une seule
chose pas tout petit détail le trophée
les valises
voilà qui sera le 46e président des
états unis ce soir trump hebeisen sont
au coude à coude le suspense est intense
et cela pourrait durer encore quelques
jours alors on va vous expliquer
pourquoi dans un instant avec tarik al
dit géraldine cornella vos journalistes
alina également présent à nos côtés sur
ce plateau etienne et dark le chef du
service de politique internationale de
france télévisions un scénario
exceptionnel mais pas inédit en 2000
déjà il avait fallu attendre un mois
pour voir al gore et de georges de
bellio bouche départager retour sur cet
incroyable imbroglio politique avec ce
sujet de jérémy gap
novembre 2000 jamais une élection
présidentielle américaine n'avait créé
autant de suspense
à l'époque le républicain george w bush
et le démocrate al gore sont au coude à
coude dans les sondages
le 7 novembre jour de scrutin aucun des
deux candidats n'est déclaré vainqueur
s'ils sont forts ces américains
l'élection présidentielle de cette nuit
est un modèle d'un scénario hollywoodien
avec rebondissements coup de théâtre et
un suspense total
la faute à un état celui de la floride
un swing states état pivot en français
ou le résultat est indécis jusqu'au bout
sur 5 million deux cent mille bulletins
dépouillés en floride
il y a vingt mille voix d'écart vingt
mille voix en faveur de georges bush
mais monsieur gore est en train de
revenir finalement bouche remporte de la
floride et ses 25 grands électeurs mais
la joie est de courte durée chez les
républicains
en floride les résultats sont si serrés
que la loi oblige un nouveau décompte
à l'aide d'une machine au pays de
l'oncle sam le nom du prochain président
se fait attendre
en tant que citoyenne je voudrais savoir
qui sera mon prochain président or on ne
le saura peut-être même pas ce soir ou
dandy jouer là encore bouche l'emportent
mais le camp démocrate ne s'arrête pas
là ils réclament un nouveau comptage
dans trois comtés de floride des
partisans d'al gore ont mal poinçonné
leur bulletin
la présentation des candidats prêtait à
confusion conséquence des électeurs
démocrates ont voté par mégarde pour le
candidat ultraconservateur pas de bus
can
avant de se reprendre et de sélectionner
al gore les démocrates obtiennent que
ces bulletins invalidés soit finalement
prise en compte nous allons gagner car
l'injustice ne saurait l'emporté sur la
justice
chez les républicains ce nouveau
décompte ne passe pas on a tous reçu un
exemplaire du bulletin de vote avant les
élections les explications sont
parfaitement claires si vous avez fait
une erreur vous pouvez rendre votre
bulletin et en prendre un autre
alors ceux qui se sont trompés j'en suis
désolé pour eux mais leur vote compte ce
n'est pas une raison pour en voter un
recours en justice et même déposés par
les républicains
avant d'être rejeté le comptage manuel
se poursuit mais le 26 novembre 2001
coup de théâtre se produit je déclare le
gouverneur du texas george deubeuliou
gauche vainqueur des 25 grands électeurs
de l'état de floride
la secrétaire d'état de floride annonce
la victoire du candidat républicain et
sans attendre les résultats officiels
les démocrates comptent est le nouveau
recours sont déposés
encore une fois les américains se
réveille sans président les gens ont
voté
on a déjà dépouillés les bulletins on a
compté une fois deux fois
je pense que l'algue heures devrait
admettre sa défaite et que bush doit
devenir président finalement le 12
décembre 2000 plus d'un mois après le
scrutin
la cour suprême des etats-unis décident
de bloquer le recomptage manuel des voix
georges de bellio bouche devient
officiellement le 43e président des
états unis
voilà pour cette présidentielle
en l'an 2000 qui rappelle beaucoup de
souvenirs autour de cette table on va
aller voir loïc de la mornais notre
envoyé spécial à wilmington dans le
delaware dans le qg de joe biden
bouchard loïc un tel scénario est il
possible cette année ou au centre up
hebeisen ce soir
et bien nathanel comme vous le savez un
des deux côtés il y a des armées
d'avocats qui sont prêtes à les explorer
toutes les pistes juridiques possibles
alors il ya deux éléments d'abord sur
les recomptages c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
demandé un donald trump de faire un
recomptage dans l'état du wisconsin qui
vient d'être gagnée par joe baydan c'est
tout à fait possible et recomptages
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait légal
qui répondent à des des lois différentes
en fonction de chaque état après
l'expérience et l'histoire a montré que
ces recomptage généralement joue sur
quelques centaines de voix pas sur des
milliers de voix est là il ya quand même
plusieurs milliers de voix d'avancé pour
joe biden après il ya cette question de
la cour suprême c'est vrai qu'elle peut
intervenir elle en a parfaitement le
droit mais attention il faut que la cour
suprême s'autosaisit d'une affaire il ne
suffit pas que donald trump disent je
veux que la cour suprême s'en occupent
non la cour suprême elle-même va décider
s'il s'agit d'une vraie affaire d'une
vraie entorse à la loi ou pas est
effectivement là dessus alors la cour
suprême c'est vrai elle est très
conservatrice encore plus que depuis que
donald trump a pu nommer la troisième
juge conservatrice et me barrette
mais elle dit quand même la loi ce sont
quand même des magistrats et des juges
professionnels et donc les lois sont
très clairs sur les bulletins envoyés
par courrier ce sont des lois
parfaitement officiel il sera quand même
difficile pour l'équipe de donald trump
d'aller contester des lois si choquant
même écrite sur le papier très
clairement et donc encore une fois rien
rien n'est joué sur ses affaires et ses
tentatives juridique
merci beaucoup loïc tarik une des
données importantes à de cette élection
c'est bien sûr le vote anticipé une
spécificité du système électoral
américain
quel système on n'a pas tous ces
problèmes en france est assez simple on
vote le dimanche
au bureau de vote ou par procuration et
c'est tout mais les états unis nathanel
17 fois plus grand que la france
beaucoup plus peuplée des populations
parfois isolés alors il a fallu un peu
arriverai rivaliser de créativité 1 pour
faciliter ce vote en plus on voit que le
mardi aux etats-unis en pleine semaine
tout ça c'est très compliqué c'est ce
que nous résume un peu rejet gicquel
dans un lancement de 1976 on vote
comment et pour qui est bien cela va du
simple bulletin manuscrit pour comment
au vote
la carte perforée ya même des bureaux de
vote expérimentaux à new york pour le
vote vidéo avec des boutons et un cadran
voilà une multitude de modes de vote on
va laisser de côté
cette histoire de votre vidéo mais on va
parler d'eux celui par cartes perforées
alors on va le voir sur les images qui
arrivent des images de 1976 ce vote il
ressemble à un petit carton avec le nom
des candidats une case à côté il ya plus
qu à perforer et c'est un bulletin
validé les états unis vote de cette
manière depuis 1964 alors génial me
direz vous sauf que parfois ce vote il a
mis une sacrée pagaille dans les
élections
et ça c'était y'a pas si longtemps
flamand tard il n'y a pas si longtemps
on l'a vu dans le reportage en début de
début d'émission
en 2000 il y a vingt ans ces fameux 16
mille dix neuf mille votes invalidés par
dans dix neuf mille votes invalidés en
floride parce que perforé deux fois
perforé deux fois ces votes et sans
compter des électeurs qui n'ont pas bien
lu ses cartes on va voir tout ça dans
une petite sélection d'archivés c'était
en 2000 ça n'est pas avant le 17
novembre prochain soit dans une semaine
que l'on connaîtra les résultats
officiels à moins que sur ce plateau de
télé ce qui lève la main sont ceux qui
ont eu le sentiment d'avoir
involontairement voter contre leurs
candidats tous induit en erreur par le
libellé ambiguë des bulletins place en
côte à côte d'or le démocrate et
buchanan l'homme de l'extrême droite ce
n'est qu'une demi heure après que j'ai
réalisé que j'avais voté buchan and news
corp dans les rues de west palm beach il
continue de réclamer le droit de revoter
ses électeurs s'estime trompés ils font
partie des dix neuf huit citoyens de
floride dont le bulletin a été invalidée
parce qu'il avait été et prince au nez
de fruits cette voie qu'on vient
d'entendre elle vous est peut-être
familière c'est la vôtre et celle des
n'arrete pas plus quand vous venez de
l'ambiance à l'époque en 2000 dans les
rues oui je me souviens que j'avais les
cheveux aussi et c'était une ambiance
absolument incroyable pour avoir fait le
voyage de miami pendant plusieurs jours
de voir ces deux camps de supporteurs
qui s'affrontaient pendant qu'à
l'intérieur des locaux on recomptait
finalement on pourrait se dire que si
aujourd'hui la même chose arriver dans
quelques jours dans quelques semaines
dans une amérique à ces fractures et
assez divisés ça pourrait être
potentiellement explosif il ya vu des
suspicions de fraudes déjà cette époque
là bien sûr c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
les uns et les autres étaient
face à face dans les rues et donc on se
demandait un petit peu comment les
choses allaient se passer d'autant que
georges de bellio bush était candidat et
que c'est son frère jeff bush qui était
le gouverneur de l'état de floride et
donc on disait qu'il y avait une
collision familial et que collusion
familial et que probablement l'un allait
essayer d'aider l'autre alors je vais
poser la question intéresse mais
j'aimerais avoir votre avis etienne
vous êtes resté correspondant de france
télévisions aux états unis pendant
plusieurs années at-on retenu les leçons
de ce cafouillage 2000 pour l'élection
suivante alors on les a retenus en
floride clairement parce que pour les
l'état de floride ça a été un cataclysme
on a même parlé de guerre dans l'état
enfin comme si le pays était avait été
dévasté par une guerre parce que la
floride a été la risée du monde entier
et donc on en a tiré les enseignements
et on a totalement réorganisé le système
de vote savait que ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que les votes aux états
unis s'est organisée par compte et si
votre compte et n'a pas beaucoup
d'argent
il se débrouille comme il peut et à
l'époque on se débrouille avec des des
cartons perforés depuis beaucoup de deux
comtés ont informatisé leur système de
vote auto en floride ça s'est concrétisé
commentaire
ça s'est concrétisé par des petites
mesures des précautions
déjà avant l'élection des citoyens qui
faisait du porte-à-porte pour des
actions de pédagogie on explique aux
gens comment bien voter mais beaucoup
plus étonnant le jour de l'élection dans
les bureaux de vote dès des précautions
assez incroyable que nous raconte david
pujadas en 2004 depuis une édition
spéciale à new york
chacun a en mémoire le désordre d'il ya
quatre ans où il avait fallu attendre
très longtemps pour connaître le nom du
vainqueur alors des milliers des
dizaines de milliers d'observateurs dans
les deux camps se sont massés dans les
bureaux de vote
plus surprenant encore il y a pour cette
élection est pour la première fois des
observateurs internationaux
d'ordinaire on les trouve plutôt dans
les états du tiers-monde lorsqu'il ya
des élections cette fois ci ils sont aux
etats unis
reportage en floride maryse burgot
philippe jasmin le superviseur des
élections à tallahassee en floride a
décidé de rester zen toute la journée
c'est donc avec philosophie qu'il
accompagne cet observateur mexicain venu
s'assurer du bon déroulement du scrutin
aux etats unis
le superviseur a dû aussi accepté la
présence d'avocats des deux camps à
l'intérieur des bureaux de vote mais
aussi à l'extérieur
celui ci est payé par le camp
républicain
le but c'est de s'assurer que tous les
gens qui sont inscrits puissent voter
des avocats des observateurs c'est
limite s'il ya plus de monde pour un peu
vérifier cette élection que des lecteurs
une question et n est ce que c'est un
dispositif qu'on a retrouvé sur les
élections qui ont suivi
absolument et c'est un dispositif qui
existe toujours aujourd'hui et nous
avons montré hier dans un reporter du
journal télévisé comment les shérifs
aujourd'hui du cour des comptes et en
floride assiste au dépouillement
notamment des votes par correspondance
c'est une façon aussi de contrôler pour
lorsque si d'aventuré il ya des recours
et on vient d'entendre que dans certains
états donald trump qui avait perdu
souhaité faire un recomptage et bien de
montrer que le dépouillement a été
suivie et correctement suivies ça paraît
fou quand même que dans la première
démocratie du monde et c'est pas ça oui
certes mais on a vu qu'il y avait eu
quand même des gros cataclysme
électoraux et donc finalement prendre
ses précautions et mettre en place des
systèmes qui permettent d'avoir un vote
qui apparaît comme un vote démocratique
et régulier
c'est pas forcément anodin d'ailleurs là
on parlait de 2004 il ya aussi eu une
évolution technique
en plus des cartes perforées qu'on a
déjà vu tout à l'heure il y avait la
carte magnétique qu'on met dans la
machine alors ça paraît simple comme ça
de prime abord on a un écran on appuie
sur le candidat et le vote est validé
mais on est toujours en floride et il ya
toujours ce traumatisme dans l'esprit de
tous les électeurs ils sont nombreux à
ne pas avoir confiance en ce système là
notamment parce que cette machine qui
permet de voter ne donne pas de reçu
comme preuve du vote
cette absence de bulletins en papier a
fait renaître toutes les rumeurs de
manipulation des votes la justice s'est
saisie de la faire une affaire qui n'a
rien avec de tic pour ruth pelé va anti
bush convaincu je suis très inquiète
je ne comprends pas pourquoi la machine
ne remet pas en reçu à chaque électeur
après son vote même quand on achète un
tube de rouge à lèvres on a un reçu bon
finalement il n'y a pas eu de
contestations george abela bouge a été
réélu à ce que etienne c'était important
pour lui d'être nettement et sans
contestation
élu dès le soir de l'élection oui parce
qu'il se souvenait des quatre ans de
quatre ans auparavant et donc d'une
certaine manière son élection avait été
tellement contesté qu'on lui a fait un
procès en illégitimité alors que au
final la cour suprême avait tranché
donc là encore une fois les choses
étaient claires nettes et le président
qui faisait son deuxième et donc dernier
mandat a pu terminer d'une certaine
manière sa présidence même si le
deuxième mandat n'a pas été forcément de
tout repos pour lui alors 2004 c'est
important c'est aussi le lan et le début
du vote anticipé tarik votre qui fait
aujourd'hui beaucoup parler de lui 2004
il commence à gagner du terrain le
voyait déjà un tout petit peu dans les
années 90 est assez marginal mais c'est
surtout en 2008 qu'il prend de l'ampleur
un électeur sur trois en 2008 a fait le
choix du vote par correspondance et je
rappelle que aux états unis on vote le
mardi 1 donc en pleine semaine c'est
quand même plus facile de voter par
anticipation
pourquoi à l'origine on a mis en place
ce vote et jens une histoire
d'abstention c'est il faut rappeler que
l'élection présidentielle aux états unis
à peine 50 % de participation
d'une manière générale donc pour essayer
d'encourager la démocratie en fait
pourquoi est ce qu'on fait de vote
anticipé parce que les gens qui vont au
boulot le mardi
s'il faut qu'il fasse mais il faut poser
sa journée des opérations pendant des
heures avant de pouvoir voter
eh bien ils vont se dire finalement je
renonce et donc on a mis en place ce
système qui permet de voter par
anticipation et on voit que 20 ans après
où seize ans après ça a considérablement
augmenté puisque cette année plus de 100
millions d'électeurs avaient voté avant
l'ouverture des bureaux
hier matin c'est que le scellement va
retourner 12 ans en arrière en 2008 donc
trente deux états se mettent au vote
anticipé et malgré le dispositif de
sécurité assez important on va le voir
sur les images qu'ils aillent les votes
sont placés dans des cages donc on peut
se dire que c'est sécurisé qu'il n'y
aura pas forcément de fraude mais malgré
ces images de cash qu'on voit malgré ce
dispositif est bien il y a toujours le
le le
phantom de 2001 qui plane sur cette
élection et on n'a pas tout à fait
confiance à tel point que en floride
justement il ya une citoyenne qui s'est
présenté au bureau avec une caméra pour
filmer tout ça on va voir ça dans une
archive de 2008
dans la salle un militante caméra au
poing suzanne d'un champ de savoir qui a
eu accès à ces bulletins de vote
je crois que les citoyens de se compter
et moi même avons le droit de savoir et
de comprendre quelles sont les mesures
qui ont été prises pour assurer la
sécurité de ses bulletins électoraux
elle vise la responsable républicaine
des élections soupçonné de vouloir
introduire défaut parmi les vrais
bulletins pour couper court aux soupçons
de fraude
le jus l'autorisent à assister au
dépouillement juge accepte qu'elle
laxiste au dépouillement n'imagine pas
ça en france c'est une image normal ça
vous était toujours en floride cette
saison en floride
c'est toujours en force avait créé un
tel traumatisme cette histoire que
certains juges ont préféré une espèce
comme ça de deux volontés de 2,2 de
montrer la vérité jusque jusqu'au bout
et donc on a autorisé la hanche voilà on
n'a pas autorisé tous les électeurs
parce que sinon il y aurait beaucoup de
monde dans les bureaux de vote mais en
l'occurrence cette séquence
effectivement été assez marquante faut
en tout cas pas de problème avec la
floride
cette année remporté par donald trump
mais c'est une conséquence d'ailleurs de
l'histoire l'est la floride a été un des
premiers états à donner ses résultats
parce qu'ils sont mieux organisés qui a
maintenant émission exceptionnelle et
bien un zapping exceptionnel l'inattendu
revient sur les différentes soirées
d'élections américaines
organisé par la télévision française
regardez bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
george bush vient de passer la barre
fatidique des 270 dents et lecteurs
depuis quelques minutes il est le 41e
président des états unis john est notre
homme pousse bougent dans le bon sens
clinton la voix cassée s'adresse une
dernière fois la foule à partir de
demain hillary al gore keeper et moi
allons faire de notre mieux pour que
vous soyez toujours fier de cette news
historique
une à une les forteresses républicaine
viennent de tomber
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes heureux
[Applaudissements]
m
chez hillary clinton la fête n'aura
jamais lieu
la candidate ne viendra même pas
s'exprimer elle laisse ses militants
désespéré je voudrais m'excuser auprès
du monde entier si la wii à 100 mais je
ne peux pas croire qu autant d'électeurs
et voter pour un candidat qui soit
sinophobe raciste
en manteau misogyne sectaire et menteur
j'ai l'espoir d'un sort à tous unis la
nasa
on va danser ensemble bonsoir et à
demain voilà inattendu consacrée à
l'élection américaine une information
tient ça vient de tomber trump a décidé
de déposer un recours pour suspendre le
dépouillement en pennsylvanie voilà vous
pouvez le constater les enjeux de ce
scrutin sont immenses et dépasse la
frontière américaine bien sûr un
économie environnement diplomatie le
président des états unis seront
présentés comme l'homme le plus
important de la planète en tout cas il
est incontournable géraldine vous vous
êtes penché sur les relations
entretenues par le passé entre les
présidents français et les présidents
américains oui petit rappel historique
un déjà de la relation des deux pays
ce sont deux pays alliés depuis fort
longtemps depuis la guerre
d'indépendance où la france était allié
des états unis seconde guerre mondiale
évidemment où les gi's sont venus
libérer la france de l'occupation
allemande
on pourrait croire à une relation
vraiment d'amitié très forte entre ces
deux pays mais c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça par exemple dernier
mandat trump macron pendant quatre ans
ça a été une relation vraiment entre
défiance et amabilité un petit mélange
savoureux
on se souvient vous le voyez sur les
images de la réception de donald trump à
paris le 14 juillet 2010 est le salon
impressionné l'américain avait été reçu
avec tous les honneurs avait été très
impressionnant avait voulu faire la même
chose et avaient fait la même chose aux
états unis ça c'est pour l'image
sympathique mais il ya eu aussi
plusieurs accrochages par exemple sur le
la gestion du nucléaire iranien autre
point de discorde
l'accord de paris un accord ou trump
c'était était parti de cet accord de
paris très rapidement à un accord sur le
climat et macron ne mâchait pas ses mots
autre pierre dans le jardin de donald
trump l'accord de paris sur le climat
dénoncé par le président américain
there is no planet pis il n'y a pas de
planète b
anna monsieur et je suis sûr que les
etats-unis reviendront un jour dans
l'accord de paris voit clairement la
politique de trump et dénoncé pendant
quatre ans ça a été un mélange entre
grosses poignées de main virile mes
tweets complètement enflammé quel est le
bilan de ces quatre de ces quatre années
etienne dès son arrivée le président de
la république a essayé de créer une
relation personnelle avec donald trump
parce qu'ils pensaient que cette
relation personnelle allait l'aider à le
convaincre sur certains dossiers
effectivement et la relation personnelle
quand le l'on en parle aux entourages la
relation personnelle reste bonne le
problème c'est que il l'a pas été il ya
pas eu de retour sur investissement et
donc forcément au bout de quatre ans le
bilan politique il est il est assez
maigre mais est ce que le président de
la république avait le choix de faire
autrement
boudet ça n'aurait pas mené à grand
chose donc au final il a il a tenté de
faire de faire ce pari là qui n'a pas
vraiment fonctionné
voilà ça c'est pour les relations
récentes auparavant par le passé quelles
ont été les relations entre les
présidents français et américain jordi
alors plusieurs cas de figure ainsi on
remonte par exemple au général de gaulle
c'est la mésentente cordiale
sur le papier pourtant quand il reçoit
kennedy à paris en 1961 c'est une vraie
lune de miel
écoutez le ton de ce reportage le
président kennedy avait dit je vais en
france pour contribuer aux relations
étroites qui doivent permettre de
sauvegarder la cause de la liberté
et dès le premier moment on pouvait
penser que ces deux hommes qui
représentent chacun des intérêts
différents parfois mais un esprit commun
pouvait bâtir une oeuvre utile à la paix
alors on l'a entendu assez dithyrambique
la télévision de l'époque en était
vraiment entrée libre
bien sûr mais malgré ces preuves
d'amitié l'indépendance de la france
passera au dessus de tous pour le
président du et le vin le général de
gaulle il contestait à voix haute
l'hégémonie américaine et il restera
évidemment le président qui a quitté le
temps voilà une ambiance tendue donc
avec de gaulle on l'a bien vu mais les
rapports évolué au début des années 80
même si cela n'a pas été totalement
immédiat gérable
oui hein quand mitterrand arrive au
pouvoir en étant 1980 un petit point de
contexte on est en pleine guerre froide
mitterrand est un président socialiste
est dans son gouvernement il ya quatre
ministres communistes de quoi effrayer
et je pèse mes mots
les américains mais écoutez comment
mitterrand a réussi ces aléas les
convaincre quatre membres comme les
gouvernements sont des gens très qui
chavaux jose qui sont à l'école qui ont
beaucoup réfléchi qui ont même un niveau
un coefficient à cui cui champ
intellectuel tout à fait comparable
disons à g de la moyenne de nos
assemblées
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
étonne quel ministre communiste dans le
gouvernement français voilà la réalité
je me suis accordé le droite et choisir
les ministres là où je le voulais là où
je le voulais par rapport à mes
engagements à l'égard du peuple français
et je vais dire quelque chose qui va
vous paraître tout à fait détestable je
ne le regrette pas alors on le sent
complètement détendu un françois
mitterrand et il est détendu
parce qu'en fait il vit une véritable
histoire d'amitié avec
l'ultralibéralisme tregan ça peut
paraître complètement fou et pourquoi
alors cette histoire d'amitié tout
simplement parce qu'en juillet 1981 donc
juste quelques mois après l'élection de
françois mitterrand il a dévoilé au
président américain toutes les
informations qu'il détenait d'un agent
double du kgb une histoire d'espionnage
cette taupe au nom de code de farrou
elle a donc permis une relation heureuse
entre la france et les états unis
c'est fou etienne que voilà la relation
entre ces deux pays ces deux puissances
tiennent à un homme à une taupe du kgb
oui mais peut-être pas que ça mais c'est
vrai que cette affaire a créé à recréer
du lien entre
la france de françois mitterrand et les
états unis de ronald reagan et elle a eu
surtout des conséquences stratégiques
mondiales absolument considérable parce
qu'à partir de ce moment là à partir du
moment où les états unis ont compris que
les l'union soviétique les espionner et
les déstabiliser et bien le président
reagan a lancé une offensive qui mènera
quelques années plus tard au
démantèlement de l'union soviétique
alors on parle de cette bonne relation
mitterrand regan il ya eu d'autres aussi
relations plutôt positive entre les
présidents français et américain oui
bien sûr et le plus américanophile de
tous les précédents c'est évidemment
jacques chirac il a fait douze visites
aux etats unis c'est un record il amorce
même un retour de la france au sein de
l'otan et symbole de cette bonne entente
j'étais obligé de vous montrer un
archives de ses conférences de presse
avec une super bonne ambiance avec
clinton
on regarde c'était mémorable les clinton
vient d'expliquer ce qu'il entend par
politiques de gauche ou de droite et il
plaisante
moi je suis encore un peu à la gauche d'
attila le hun si j'ai bien compris
assure la production était exact ce dont
je ne doute pas le président qu'une
plainte a indiqué qu'il était à gauche
date il alors je voudrais vous dire je
ne me suis pas sentie visée coin que
quoi que puisse en penser certains
journalistes français nous voilà jacques
chirac avait des liens très particuliers
avec les américains il a même été le
premier président étranger à venir à new
york en 2001 suite aux attentats
mais voilà tout bascule en 2003 lorsque
la france décide de ne pas faire la
guerre en irak
le clash est totalement historiques
certains américains boycotte les
produits français
george deubeuliou bush ne se gênait pas
pour critiquer le président le président
chirac
il a fallu attendre 2004 et françois
hollande avec lui sa relation avec obama
pour que de nouveaux seins de français
soit invitée en visite d'état officielle
c'est qu'en 2014 2004 voilà etienne pour
conclure un mot sur byden ou trump à la
maison blanche
qu'est ce que ça changerait pour la
france sur le plan de la politique
étrangère américaine si joe biden est
élu on va retrouver
un fonctionnement beaucoup plus
multilatérale ça ne veut pas dire que
les états unis vont faire de l'europe un
un allié nouveau à les états unis
regardent aujourd'hui vers l'asie
l'europe devra tendre la main aux
américains c'est pas le contraire qui va
se passer mais les relations
diplomatiques seront disons un tout
petit peu plus normalisée que si donald
trump reste si donald trump reste à la
maison blanche
on va avoir de sérieuses anicroche avec
l'administration américaine et on va
voir ce qui va se passer dans les
prochaines heures les prochains jours
les prochaines années merci beaucoup
etienne leenhardt merci à vous géraldine
l'inattendu spécial élections
américaines c'est terminé on se retrouve
mercredi prochain toujours à 21 heures
toujours sur le canal 27